welcome to pi data global 2020 and i
definitely want to thank you for being a
speaker that
since this is your time i'll just go
ahead and
hand off right to you thank you steven
uh hello everyone i am natalie i am
senior data scientist at saturn cloud
and today i would be talking to you
about getting started with dusk using
saturn cloud
okay so before deep diving into any of
the data sciences stuff i want to talk
to you about formula one
so whenever there is a formula one
tournament uh there is a pit stop this
pit stop lasts for generally two to four
seconds
in fact the shortest pit stop has been
of one point eight four seconds
and in the small time many tasks are
done uh refueling is done some
mechanical adjustments are made and the
tires are changed
how is it possible to do so many tasks
in such a small time it is possible
because we have n number of people
working together they are
working all in parallel there is this
one big task which is pit stop but then
they are dividing this task into small
parts and this is exactly what parallel
computing is that is dividing the
problem into small parts and solving it
at the same time
okay so why do we need parallel
computing in data science
python is a friendly language and it is
quite popular among data scientists but
on its own it is not fast enough so
there is this lock which is known as
global interpreter lock uh i won't be
going into the detail of what this lock
is but what happens because of this log
is that python cannot utilize
uh multi threading for cpu intensive
calculations
so we would need some tool kit so that
we can enable the distribution of work
amongst multiple cores if you are using
a single machine or amongst
multiple machines if you are using
something like task distributed
okay so
what all can we do with parallel
computing in data science and where all
can it be used uh imagine you have a
bunch of files or you have
uh some data which has billions of lines
and you are trying to load this data on
your machine you might run out of memory
because
your data is so large that
the memory of your machine is not big
enough for that it has happened with me
so many times that i
want to do some hyper parameter tuning
or trying to uh just run something train
my model i started i go out i come back
and my model is still running it
sometimes takes so many hours so for all
these
scenarios if we have parallel computing
then we will have more memory and we
will have uh we can run all these
computations much faster
okay so of all the toolkits on the right
you see there is dust there is spark
there is tray
and there are some more so of all these
toolkits we are going to talk about dusk
today so
what is task
so dusk is a free and open source big
advantage if you are a python user
because the
the debugging becomes really easy so uh
spark is also a popular toolkit for
parallel computing um but so it has if
you compare it with task um there are
pros and cons uh so das is lightweighted
that means that
it cannot support all the languages and
like spark but if you are a python user
then task is a great tool to
use because it can integrate very nicely
with the existing python ecosystem
okay third
third point
task will increase the speed of your
computation so it can provide you
scalability for your machine learning
and data science workflows and the best
part is is that task is easy
that means that if you know how to write
your functions using some anything uh
standard like pandas numpy sackettler
then writing those functions and
adding scalability utilizing task is not
very tough we will talk more about this
later as well
okay so
we will be using uh some of the codes
going along and the data which i will be
using is of kegel it is a formula one
dataset
and it is not times dot csv so here we
have race id we have driver id we have
labs we have positions and we have the
time taken for each lab
let's talk about das networks now
so das networks constitute of three
things client scheduler and workers
so when you are writing some code uh
that is like a user facing entry point
that is what is known as client now when
you are writing a code you are giving
some commands these commands are
transferred to the scheduler so
scheduler takes these commands and then
it manages the workers that means that
it is assigning it is distributing the
task to these workers and the workers
are the one who are actually performing
all the computations in parallel
okay
so
user interfaces which are used in dusk
so task has two kinds of user interfaces
one is high level and one is low level
so the high level one is where
which is like the scalable version of
numpy pandas cyclone etc uh so the
standard interface remains same that
when i say standard interface remains
same it means that the syntax which you
are using already when using pandas
numpy circuit loan you would be using
the same kind of syntax here but
under the hood dusk will be working via
parallel computing so all the
computations will be much much faster
okay so what are the low level interface
uh now suppose that you started writing
your code in single node uh for example
you were writing your code in pandas
and then after some time you realized
okay i should have used some scalability
my
this computation is taking a lot of time
and you don't want to convert it into
dash data frame at that time
uh in that case
you can just wrap it around das delayed
or task features and we will be talking
and seeing the examples as well uh in
detail later
okay
so let's check some task collections the
first one is dash data frame
so das data frame can be thought of as a
bunch of pandas data frame
so when you are using pandas data frame
all the computations are done single
threaded way uh but task data frame uh
it uses the partitions so the
computations are done in parallel on all
the data frames so let's check the
example on the left hand side
um
you can see both the codes one is using
pandas one is using dash data frame more
or less both
of them look quite similar
um
so but under the hood the fun how they
are working is quite different so uh
check the second line where i'm
reading the csv file so when i do that
in pandas
pandas is going to read the file
literally from starting to the end end
to end but when i'm doing the same thing
with das data frame
it is just going to read enough as per
the information that it needs that is it
is just going to be columns and also
what other data types and that's it why
because task is lazy
and actually that's what makes it faster
it is not going to read all the lines it
is only going to read all these lines
and do all the computations on that when
it is explicitly asked to do so so if
you check the second line on the last
line um i'm trying to find the mean lap
time for each driver here so the syntax
looks same group by mean uh just that
when i'm using task data frame i'm
adding dot compute in the end so
adding that dot compute means that i am
now explicitly telling dust to do the
computation
okay task areas
so dark areas can be thought of as bunch
of numpy errors
uh so the computation in dark areas is
done
in blocks
uh let's check the example on the right
hand side
uh so
here i have a numpy array with
which i have converted to task array and
it is in two by two chunks so that means
that i have got four blocks uh so now
when i have to do some computation let's
say like dot sum
so the computation will be done in all
these four blocks in parallel and once
the computation is done in all four
blocks in parallel only then these four
will be added so if you compare it to
with the summation when i'm using just
numpy array dash array in this case is
four times small faster minus the
overhead
okay task backs
so dashbox can be thought of as a bunch
of lists but why do we need dust bags
when we already
have task data frames
so sometimes our data is not structured
it is unstructured or it is
semi-structured
so performing some functions like
mapping like filtering all these are
very easy when you
do those in task tags
okay so let's check the example here
uh i have a json file which has some
information
about some formula one drivers and i
want to take out the name of the drivers
whose rank is less than 10. so in this
case because it's a json file and i want
to do some pre-processing clean my data
i would be using dash bags and once uh
the cleaning is done
then we can convert this into the flat
columns and do the computations for
machine learning later in task data
frames
okay
now coming back to the low level
interface let's revise what we had
learned earlier
we would be using low level interface
when we already have our code ready
which is let's say for example in pandas
and we do not want to convert it into uh
task data frames for example or any
other high level interface or maybe
uh
sometimes the computations are
complicated enough that doing those in
task on its own might get
maybe complex so in these cases you can
just use your pre-existing code and wrap
it around dash delay
but how does das delayed actually works
let's take a look
so coming back to cars again uh let's
say that you have to build a car there
are two ways to build a car the first
one is that someone gives you
instruction one let's say put on a tire
one you do that you are given second
instruction that
put on a tire two you do that and go
back again and this happens the entire
day to and fro the other way to do is
that someone gives you a list of
instructions you check that list and
then when you think the time is right
you call your nine other friends and
then
all of you walk in paddle and try to
build the car in the most optimized way
this is exactly how dusty it works
it does not
compute every time a function is given
to it it just creates a task graph and
then it waits to be explicitly called
and then only it uh does all the
computations in parallel
uh we we will see an example here first
so
uh i have three functions here and this
is in pandas so in
first one i'm trying to find the maximum
time of the lab the second one finding
the minimum time of the lab and then i'm
finding the range
so the c variable is giving me the
output for range here now
i want to add scalability to this
function for that i am going to wrap it
around dash delay so when i'm calling
here c
variable again
you don't see the result instead
you see an object why is it so because
task is lazy it is not going to perform
the com
reputations until explicitly to
do so so all this time it is not doing
any competition instead it is preparing
a graph a task graph so on my right hand
side you can see the task graph that das
delete prepared um and it is trying to
find ways it can optimize all the
functions so since
my finding maximum lap time and finding
minimum lap time are not related to each
other it is performing these it will be
performing these computations in
parallel
so and once in the last line if you see
c dot compute that is when it is
actually explicitly performing the
computations
okay so
it might happen that uh
there are some computations which are
real time which which you want results
like immediately in that case you have
an alternative to das delete which is
task features so it extends the python's
concrete futures interface
and it is not lazy it performs the
computations immediately
so in this example um i have the same
functions which i was using before
but
here i'm calling each function one by
one
dot submit so
dot submit will be transferring this
task to the scheduler will be which will
be passing it to the workers which will
be performing it in parallel and this
result will be saved in a remote thread
and this result will be called as soon
as you do c dot result so and also it's
a personal choice sometimes people
prefer using das features over dusty
late
okay now let's get back to formula one
let's say lewis hamilton's ultimate aim
is to drive
a car fast he has got two options either
he can build a car himself
and then drive fast or
he can let mercedes build a car for him
and then drive fast which one do you
think he chose i think he's telling us
the answer
so now
let's get the options
first one is that they build the
clusters themselves manage their
clusters themselves
kubernetes and
all the infrastructures issues all that
they have another option
they let saturn cloud do all the weight
lifting and they just concentrate on
doing some research work building their
models nicely or on making decisions so
let's see that how we can create task
clusters using saturn cloud
so this is the saturn cloud website by
the way you can start using saturn cloud
for free we give you 64 gb of cpu we
give you free dusk and we give you gpu
along with that
so once you log into saturn cloud uh you
will see some resources here
so resources can be thought of as
computation environment and um
which where each computation environment
is connected to a hardware
so some of the resources here you see
these are all pre-built resources um
that means that you can just click in
and then start working everything is
ready for you or if you want you can
build resources yourself as well make
some choices so
whenever anyone has to create task
cluster in general they have to have a
resource associated with it it can be a
job it can be a deployment or it can be
a jupiter server so let's let's use a
jupiter server here
so i choose the typical server i
choose myself that how powerful i want
my hardware to be
and then i click on
new dash cluster
so in just few clicks i can determine
that what should be the scheduler size
what should be the worker size or how
many workers i want or how many cores i
want in each process and that's it now
you start your jupiter server you start
your task cluster
and you land into the very familiar page
which is jupiter labs
so
here
you will be just importing the saturn
cluster class
and then associating your task with
saturn cluster and you don't need to use
any other attributes or anything because
your dash clusters are already ready in
just a few clicks
so here on my right hand side you can
see the information
it will show you the dash dashboard you
can see how much memory you have or what
other workers you have
so task dashboards
are
um
very imp they are quite interesting if
you want to see uh how the workers are
behaving
and
how
much are you utilizing in all these
workers so this is how a das dashboard
looks like it will show you how are you
using the workers in the most optimal
way or can you make some changes so if
you look at the
oscar thread and each rectangle that you
see in that stream that is a task so
each task has a color for itself and the
white part that you see in between that
means that at this time
the worker is idle um if you look at the
progress which is at the bottom again
the color coding is same here and it
tells you that how is the progress for
each task
and the gray part that you see there it
tells you that the task is ready to run
so this will really help you analyze
that how are tasks being done by all the
workers
on the left hand side at the top you can
also see that how much memory is
consumed by each worker
so
if you see the 6.76 gb that is the total
memory being utilized by all the workers
this is like just one example there um
there are four other dashboards that you
can see
okay
now let's
check some examples to understand that
how powerful dusk is
so the first one is hyper parameter
tuning
um
on my left hand side
i have two codes where i'm doing hyper
parameter tuning via gridset cv
so the first one is with single node and
the second one is with dusk if you look
at both the codes there is not much
difference
um for both of them um i am using grid
search cv the syntax looks almost same
just that for single load i'm using
circuit learn and for task i'm using
dash camera which is used in machine
learning
so the syntax looks same but the results
are quite different
if you look at the result
of single node it seems that it is
taking three hours to do hyper parameter
tuning and if you look at the results of
dusk for three workers it is now the
time has come back down to almost one
third which is like 64 minutes
and if you are going to use 10 workers
it takes just 20 minutes and then you
increase your workers to 20 minutes it
takes just 11 minutes so
just with few changes you can
make your hyper parameter tuning run
much faster
okay
so task is fast but can you make it
faster yes you can if you integrate
tasks with rapids but what are rapids
so rapid is a suite of open source
libraries it helps data scientists
utilize gpus in their machine learning
pipelines
so
let's take an example uh let's say you
have pandas so
pandas whenever it has to do
computations it's all computations are
done in cpu
so rapids has live set of libraries um
so example it has a cudf library
which mirrors the api of pandas so the
syntax is almost same
because of that but
instead of utilizing cpu for doing
computations
codf will utilize gpu to do all the
computations that means you are scaling
up and then when you integrate rapids
with dusk you are not only scaling up
you are doing scaling out because you
can do all these computations in
multiple machines so
when you are using let's say dusty data
frame dash data frame on its own has
is composed of bunch of pandas data
frame but when dusk and rapid get
integrated then the task uh data frame
will be composed of bunch of cudf
data frames so
the speed will be much much faster in
fact you can check this example the link
that i've provided here it has some nice
scenarios
okay
so integrating das with pi torch um
pytorch is quite popular for deep
learning and it is known fact that it
does have parallel computing when you
are on a single machine but if you use
task by torch ddp then you can use
multiple machines and distribute your
training so you can coordinate the
parameter fitting if you are training
for a model or you can run multiple
models on multiple workers and make
training much much faster check out this
blog
uh it is quite interesting for speeding
up neural network training with multiple
gpus and dusk
okay
so
wrapping up everything what we learned
today
um
task increases the speed of your
computations
dust can scale out your machine learning
workflows and data science workflows the
interface is quite familiar so if you
know
how to use pandas scikit learn switching
to task is very easy you can wrap it
around
dar steal it and means that dusk is
written in python so integrating it with
the existing software projects like
pytorch and rapids is easy and it will
make your code very efficient
so thank you everyone that's all from my
side
thank you very much for speaking out
like it
like honestly i'm not an expert myself
in data science but i actually
understood some of the points you were
making there
but yeah yeah i'm dead
you have a wonderful day and enjoy the
rest of the conference and weekend